[Music]
look at this bird flying can you think
of some functions related to its motion
we saw do such functions earlier the
distance traveled as a function of time
and its speed - as a function of time
but we also know that as the altitude
Rises the atmospheric pressure decreases
so the atmospheric pressure felt by the
bird is the function of its height above
the ground we previously saw that when
we have two quantities x and y such that
for each value of x there is one value
of y that we say that y is a function of
x so here X could be time and Y could be
the distance X can be the altitude and
wide the atmospheric pressure X could be
time and Y the speed can you think of
other functions like these let me give
you one example what do you think the
position of a book in a library is
dependent on each book in a library is
labeled using letters and numbers like
these and these letters and numbers
could be based on the subject or the
genre or addition may be so the position
of the book is dependent on some letters
and numbers any more examples that you
can think of share your thoughts in the
comment section below but just knowing
that two things depend on each other
isn't very useful to us we need to know
how they are related to each other
previously we saw that this relationship
can be given by equations like these
this equation says that the value of the
dependent variable is the square of the
value of independent variable but kind
of function like the position of a book
in a library be represented like this no
we cannot do that right we cannot
represent this function by an equation
like this in calculus we only do
with functions between two things that
can be quantified such quantifiable
functions can also be represented
visually do you remember the question we
asked in the previous video we asked
what's common between this equation and
a flashlight or a dish satellite did you
find anything the mirror in this
flashlight and this dish are similar
curved surfaces called parabolic
surfaces the special thing about such
surfaces is that in the case of a
satellite all the electric signals
falling on the dish gets reflected to
this point called the focus and in the
case of flashlight it's the opposite the
bulb inside is located at the focus
point when we turn it on all the light
rays instead of spreading in all
directions get reflected in the forward
direction now look at the cross-section
of the curved surface notice that the
whole surface is made up of curves which
look like this we've seen earlier that
this type of a curve is called a
parabola and here's the connection this
curve is the geometrical representation
of this equation or we can say that this
equation is the algebraic representation
of this curve now let's say we draw x
and y axes like this the values of
independent variable X are represented
by the points on the x axis and the
values of the dependent variable Y are
represented by the points on the y axis
here the X and the y coordinates of the
points on this curve are related based
on this relation if we take different
values of the constant K here we will
get different functions and for each
function we can draw a curve
corresponding to it just by looking at
them we can figure out how the two
functions behave relatively as the value
of the variable X increases the value of
the variable Y increases
relatively faster in this case
visualizing a function gives us an
intuition about how it works now let me
ask you a question in our previous video
we found out the rate of change in the
dependent variable with respect to the
independent variable for this function
we get this new function for the rate so
here can you tell me what this rate
means geometrically think about it and
share your thoughts in the comment
section below
so in this lesson we saw that a function
can be represented by its equation and
its graph now look at this curve can you
tell me whether this curve represents a
function or not we will continue this in
the next part this curve does not
represent a function let's understand
why for now let's first assume that this
curve represents a function we usually
denote a function in this way it's read
as f of X this notation is made up of
three things
first X here represents the independent
variable second F represents the
function itself third f of X together
represents the dependent variable which
we earlier denoted by Y another way to
write it is y equal to f of X so this
tells us that the variable Y is some
function of the variable X and that
function is denoted by the letter F such
type of notations also help us when we
want to talk about two different
functions between the same variables we
can denote them using different letters
like this
now let's come back to a question look
at this point on the x-axis we denote it
by X 1 now we see that related to X 1
there are two values of the variable Y
and that's why this curve does not
represent a function we have seen that a
function is a relation between two
variables such that for each value of
the independent variable there is only
one value of the dependent variable but
if we draw a line parallel to the y-axis
here we see that for one value of x
there are two values of y so this is not
a function drawing a vertical line like
this helps us for example look at this
curve if we traverse this curve through
a vertical line we see that at some
points the line intersects the curve at
more than one point so this curve cannot
represent a function
checking whether a curve represents a
function in this way this called the
vertical line test now let's get back to
this function and it's geometrical
representation we saw earlier notice
that in this equation for any value of
the variable X we get one value of
variable Y this can be easily seen from
its geometrical representation but now
look at this function what will be the
value of the Y variable for X equal to 1
for X equal to 1 here we get 1 divided
by 0 anything divided by 0 is undefined
now if we draw its graph it will look
like this so we see that this function
is not defined for x equal to 1 but for
all other values of x we will get one
value of y so except for x equal to 1
the function is defined for all the are
the values of X therefore we always have
to mention the collection of all the
acceptable values of X
it's called the domain of the function
and the collection of all the values of
y related to the values of X in the
domain is called the range of the
function now we have an idea about the
concept of functions now let's say we
have sets x and y both of numbers and we
are given this relation between the two
sets we can see that related to each
number in the exit there is only one
number in the Y set so this relation is
a function it can be written like this
the domain of the function is the
numbers in the set X and the range of
the function is the numbers in the set Y
but look at this relation between two
sets of numbers is this a function if it
is then what's its domain and range yes
it's a function related to each number
in set a there's only one number in set
B it doesn't matter if there are more
numbers in set a that are related to a
number in set B so what about the domain
and the range here the domain is the set
of numbers but now notice that this
number in set B is not related to any
number in set a so it's not in the range
of the function the range will be the
set of these two numbers so we can now
talk about functions in a general sense
let's move on to a new page here is a
set of things and related to each of its
elements there's only one element in
some other set this relationship is
called a function and how they are
related is usually given by an equation
or shown pictorially with the graph of
the function now let me ask you a
question why exactly are we looking at
the concept of functions in calculus as
we move along we will realize that all
the problems we discussed about in our
previous videos can be framed in terms
of functions between two variables let's
say we are given this growth of a
function then finding the solutions of
the problems we discussed earlier boils
down to two things first to find out the
steepness of a tangent line at a point
on the curve differentiation is the
process that's used here now the second
thing is to find the area of the
particular region like this under the
curve integration is the process used
here in the upcoming lessons we will see
how exactly this is done to stay updated
subscribe to our channel by clicking
here happy learning
[Music]